when Tesla was still a struggling
company in 2017 Elon Musk admitted he
fired employees who had the weakest
performance reviews and he made no
apologies for it give us two boxes of
equal ability once much smaller
the big guy is going to crush the little
guy obviously so we've got to have a
heck of a lot more skill
covered so that is why our standards are
high they're not high because we believe
in being mean to people they're high
because if they're not high we will die
he believes it's critical to separate
the good from the great his decision to
slash half of Twitter staff of 7 500 his
first week at the helm was more
controversial did he fire the least
effective employees did he even have
enough time to figure out who they were
the purge continued two weeks later in a
late night company-wide email titled a
fork in the road musk reiterated the
kind of person he wants working for him
they're the ones who work extremely
hardcore this will mean working long
hours at high intensity only exceptional
performance will constitute a passing
grade anyone who didn't commit by
clicking the enclosed link was forced to
leave the company hundreds are believed
to have headed out the door plotting
Twitter with salute emojis but musk
assured that the best people are staying
so I'm not super worried these are some
of the best people according to the boss
so what kind of a person makes the cut
under Elon Musk probably not the ones
wearing these shirts found at Twitter
headquarters and there's an entire
entire closet full of secret closet of
hashtag woke the t-shirts in all
seriousness apparently they have to be a
bit like him he's really the most driven
person I think I've ever met former NASA
astronaut Garrett riesman now works as a
consultant for SpaceX musk has famously
slept at Tesla's factories during the
most challenging times like in 2018 when
Tesla struggled with production of the
model 3. he said he was working 120
hours a week although he said the
expectations of his staff are quote much
less than I demand of myself his team
suffered along with him they were
expected to put in long hours too musk
says there was no other way to turn
Tesla around as you told journalist Kara
Swisher it is absurd at Tesla's life
absurd
absurd so what do you owe that what do
you accredit that to excruciating effort
by 100 hour weeks right by Everyone by
everyone here at Tesla yes
what is there wasn't some other way to
do this yes that's what I'm saying it
wasn't there was some other way to do
this car it was through the sheer force
of their blood and sweat and perhaps
some tears that Tesla saw the light at
the end of a long dark tunnel and
survived 2018. he's bringing that same
mentality to Twitter in 2022 he claims
the app is losing four million dollars a
day in that he has no other choice but
to cut costs and whip Twitter into shape
through extreme effort musk told Twitter
staff they are expected in the office at
least 40 hours a week and reportedly
warned them to brace for 80 hour work
weeks which would be quite the change
from what many are used to senior
Twitter engineer siru murugasan was
secretly recorded by the conservative
group project Veritas admitting he only
worked four hours a week musk believes
working extraordinary early long hours
gives an extraordinary Advantage here's
what he said in 2010 just work like hell
I mean you just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour
weeks every week
I mean if if other people are putting in
40 hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve you will achieve
in four months what it takes them a year
to achieve he's also banned working from
home for all his companies except in
exceptional circumstances as he believes
people slack off when they aren't in the
office audio leaked to ABC News reveals
that a Twitter employee challenged him
on his mandatory return to office policy
even if people return to the office the
offices are separate offices we won't be
in person anyways yes but you can still
maximized amount of in-person activity
Twitter is not one it Tesla's on one
place either basically if not if you
can't show up at an office and you do
not show up at the office resignation
accepted
and a story returning to the office will
no longer include the luxury of free
lunches a common perk at Big tech
companies musk has cut this from
Twitter's budget but it's not enough to
Simply work hard with no free food at
Elon musk's companies he's also
demanding his employees be extremely
talented musk confirmed those writing
great code will constitute the majority
of our team Twitter is a software
company at its heart where Engineers
must be on the alert when someone hacks
the system or when a major bug crashes
the system and if he wants to turn
Twitter into the everything app like
what WeChat has become in China
Engineers will be the ones tasked with
adding new features he believes a small
group of Highly talented Engineers can
be more effective than a large group of
Engineers who are just pretty good he
explained during a q a with Twitter
employees if you look at say the Tesla
autopilot AI team it's about 150
engineers and their outperforming teams
that they're competing against that are
3 000 engineers
so Twitter 2.0 is relying on a much
smaller Workforce to get more done they
also have to deal with setbacks after
musk's overhaul there's been a mass drop
in Revenue as advertisers have pulled
out unsure of the new direction under
the new boss musk tried implementing an
eight dollar a month subscription plan
for people to be verified but had to put
it on hold after some users started
impersonating Brands and now the company
must brace for what's to come after musk
allowed Donald Trump back on Twitter in
his promise to save free speech he
reversed the ban on Trump after his
Twitter poll showed people narrowly
wanted the former president back other
tech companies are watching closely
they've suffered in the post-pandemic
world meta recently laid off 11 000
people Amazon has started to cut with
layoffs continuing in 2023 if musk can
run a lean ship and be profitable herbal
this will signal to other Tech firms
that it's possible to be lean and green
but it will not be easy getting there
it's hard working for Elon Musk take it
from Dolly Singh the former head of
talent acquisition at SpaceX who
witnessed the failure of the third
launch of the falcon 1.
the predecessor to today's Falcon 9.
musk had burned through the 100 million
he put into his private rocket company
Dolly Singh admitted on the question and
answer site quora working with him isn't
a comfortable experience he is never
satisfied with himself so he is never
really satisfied with anyone around him
he pushes himself harder and harder and
he pushes others around him the exact
same way the challenge is that he is a
machine and the rest of us aren't so if
you work for Elon you have to accept the
discomfort but in that discomfort is a
kind of growth you can't get anywhere
else and worth every ounce of blood and
sweat
five four three in the case of SpaceX
persistence paid off
an investment from a venture capital
Firm made it possible for SpaceX to
attempt a fourth flight which was
ultimately successful
spacex's achievements are still being
written but the road to get to today has
not been easy for employees neither will
the road be easy for employees at its
latest company